since 1963 when we passed the Equal Pay  Act we have been talking about the fact  women are not paid equally for equal  work fast forward to the year of our  Lord 2019 and women are paid 80 cents on  the dollar black women 61 cents Native  American women 58 cents Latinas 53 cents  I'm done with the conversation so yes I  am proposing in order to deal with this  one I'm gonna require corporations to  post on their website whether they are  paying women equally for equal work too  they will be fined for every one percent  differential between what they are  paying men and women they will be fined  1% of their previous year's profits  that'll get everybody's attention  Thank You senator senator for action  senator Jill